this episode was made possible by Wix
build your own professional website with
Wix by following the link in the
description humans are pretty good at
figuring out how to make more money it's
what drives our society since the
Industrial Revolution we've put
countless hours of research and testing
into developing newer more efficient and
more profitable ways of getting our jobs
done from production lines to robotic
arms to complete automation of processes
it's easy to think that we've just about
reached the fullest potential of
efficient manufacturing but as always a
few enterprising organizations and
individuals have decided that's not good
enough we may have started to realize
diminishing returns on earth but the
completely different environment of
outer space still has mountains of
untapped potential things that we
struggle with on earth handling the
toxic byproducts of certain industries
wasting huge amounts of water to
disperse heat all of these things become
non-issues in the vacuum of space if we
can master this new environment and
mitigate the risk involved with working
in space the future of industry could
look vastly different than it does today
consider fiber optic cable for example
the technology responsible for
high-speed data transfer and long
distance telecommunication some exotic
forms of fiber optics such as Zee bland
are plagued by gravity these cables can
be made on earth but it's tricky and the
results can be poor besides length
limitations gravity causes
inconsistencies in the crystalline
structure of Zee bland making for a
weaker signal there's a huge opportunity
for businesses to improve this process
because higher quality Zee bland is
incredibly valuable the purest examples
can fetch over a million dollars per
kilogram the solution luggage sized
self-contained drop towers designed to
be launched into space to take advantage
of the microgravity environment aboard
the ISS these contraptions spool the Z
plane around inside and since far
greater amounts of starter material can
be used in low gravity environments
these devices could theoretically spool
hundreds of kilometres of Z bland per
day that's how you make a profit back on
earth but the possibilities don't stop
at profit driven ventures the
microgravity environment of the ISS is
also perfectly suited for more
humanitarian endeavors our medical
science has made great strides in stem
cell technology and biological 3d
printing in recent years our successes
have been so significant that we're on
the cusp of being able to
print entire functioning hearts from a
patient's own stem cells which would
offer the huge benefit of the organ not
being rejected by the host body and the
patient not being required to take
immunosuppressants for the rest of their
life as with fiber optics the main
challenge is gravity in order to build
heart tissue the nutrient and stem cell
mixture within the bio inks used in
printing needs to be a very liquid
consistency there's no way to achieve
this on earth at least not without some
form of scaffolding to support the ink
and scientists have yet to figure out a
way to remove the scaffolding without
damaging the completed organ printing in
space however it changes the game
completely on earth 3d printers aren't
really 3d they print by stacking
two-dimensional layers of material on
top of each other which is very
time-consuming in space
with their specially designed 3d
printers the speed is improved by up to
a hundred times in a recent test a 3d
printed human heart lost about half its
height when gravity was restored almost
immediately after printing allowed more
time to mature aboard the ISS a printed
organ would be ready for use on earth
about 45 days after printing this
technology will revolutionize the
medical industry with patients receiving
organs made from their own stem cells
with no chance of immune rejection and
without having to wait months or years
for a suitable organ donation another
application that could be both hugely
profitable and beneficial to both the
general population and the earth as a
whole would be manufacturing super
efficient solar panels in microgravity
environments gallium arsenide is a much
better conductor of solar energy than
the common silicon based panels we see
today at around 40 percent efficiency
verses 15 to 20 percent the only problem
is manufacturing these panels produces
many toxic byproducts such as arsenic
back in the 1990s a University of
Houston scientist made the first gallium
arsenide semiconductor in space the
resulting product was 10,000 times
better in quality than its earth-made
counterparts thanks to the vacuum of
space the compound could be grown in
neat layers just one atom high and
thousands of these layers stacked on top
of each other result in a defect free
product massively increasing solar
efficiency up to a theoretical 60% if we
assembled these solar panels in space
and place giant kilometer-wide arrays in
orbit so they're always facing the Sun
we could beam huge amounts of solar
energy down to facilities on earth the
vacuum of space would completely negate
the risk of toxic byproducts harming
human
or the planet and if implemented on a
large scale we'd have more solar energy
than we knew what to do with one final
application that would significantly
reduce the amount of wasted water on
earth would be manufacturing microchips
in the freezing conditions of space
according to expert estimates making a
single 12-inch integrated circuit
requires 2,200 gallons of water for the
cleaning and cooling process in 2015 we
made 900 billion of them you do the math
if we move the chip manufacturing
industry off the planet and into the
void of space you'd completely negate
that massive waste of water parts and
products could be kept at a constant low
temperature reducing costs and
environmental hazards these are just a
few of the potential changes we'll
likely see in the near future as space
becomes more commercialized and the cost
of launching materials into orbit
becomes less and less expensive we'll
see a boom in new technologies methods
of production that make our current
means look primitive businesses can look
forward to increased profits entire new
industries will spring up will reduce
our negative impact on the environment
and the general population will benefit
from new higher quality products and an
abundance of clean energy we're on the
verge of a new industrial revolution and
there's a lot to look forward to if
you're planning on being the next big
name in space manufacturing you'll need
a professional website to show everybody
how great you are why not start your
empire today with a shiny new website
from Wix with Wix you can build amazing
professional websites for just about any
application whether you want to host
videos share your photo gallery book
clients sell products or just about
anything else you could ever want
whether you need a professional website
for your own personal use or for
e-commerce music hotels or restaurants
Wix does all the heavy lifting like
hosting custom domains email marketing
and more allowing you to focus on the
creative side of things you have total
creative freedom over your websites
allowing for limitless possibilities and
you don't even have to be a web designer
Wix caters to everyone regardless of
skill level whether you're a novice
business owner or a seasoned website
builder so if you want to build your
very own professional website visit Wix
by following the link below if you
enjoyed this video consider subscribing
and clicking that little bell to stay up
to date on the latest videos if you're
not sure what to watch next
check out these playlists full of other
great content as always thanks for
watching and supporting second thought
and we'll see you next week